so how far are you coming from i come
from
south okay all the way south yeah coming
and going to head in north herron north
okay okay
yeah we are rounding up this horses oh
yeah yeah
my horses had strayed from this wapie
sean roundup
the one i'm riding has a name
buckshot
all these horses belong to the community
where these guys are from
now normally these horses are running
wild so they had to round them up
the horses are being taken to a ranch a
few days ride from here to sit out the
worst of the rainy season
as a thank you for finding their horses
the cowboys invite me for food
[Music]
i join a writer called chato
to help him set up camp
[Applause]
what is that
anaconda
right there
he's definitely freaked out horses
this monster snake is right on the trail
we got to get it safely out of the way
that big snake
here you can see those
just rows and rows
of really
sharp teeth
those
are jaws that mean business
the snake stays hidden
in
murky water like this
you can see how that camouflage
once it submerges itself just a little
bit
below the water it just simply
disappears
they're active like this one
it usually means they're looking for
prey
it's waiting for
anything that can fit into the jaws of
this snake that's fair game
and these snakes can easily
eat an animal size of a pig
wandering through these waters getting a
drink of water and
boom
and
it would constrict that prey to death so
it couldn't breathe
stops the blood flow of that animal the
animal eventually passes out
and then the animal is safe to eat it'll
find its head
and then eat whatever it caught head
first
[Music]
[Music]
you